congress has a relief bill
oh finally it's been so long since we
got a relief bill out of congress
after our elected officials told us to
completely shut down the country and
stop living our lives
you remember the first time they gave us
about 1200 bucks not all of us by the
way just some people they give 1200
bucks
uh which is you know i guess it's good
for
a week or two weeks maybe a month it's
probably not enough to get you through
11 months and congress realized that so
they passed a trillion dollar
coronavirus relief bill
and also a 1.4 trillion omnibus bill why
i don't know that's
who knows look if you spend some money
on something people really need you got
to spend a whole lot more money
on a bunch of other stuff this package
will expand
the paycheck protection program that'll
open up 248 billion dollars in funding
for struggling businesses
which we've noticed curiously very often
goes to
companies connected to politicians but
hey you'll get some money too do you
know how much money you'll get
after the government told you you've got
to stay home don't go to work get locked
up in your apartment
you will get 600 bucks 600 bucks so
600 bucks plus 1200 bucks that we got
last time
it's been 282 days since 15 days to slow
the spread
so i'm no math whiz but if i'm doing
that math right that means
that the federal government to
compensate us for shutting down our
entire lives
will pay us 6.38
a day that's if the money is received
today it won't be actually you'll be
getting a little bit less
is that going to get us through 2020
2021
however long the lockdown lasts you
better save your pennies
i'm michael knowles this michael knowles
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my favorite comment from yesterday is
from oliver scatt
who says our definition of essential
has been changed drastically i think
this is true
you know people who get on zoom calls
and teach students about gender theory
that's now essential
but the police department is not
essential
actually we've got to defund the whole
police department you see going
to the local head shop or whole foods
very essential
going to church not essential
that is not hypocrisy that's a new
standard
that is being voiced upon us
things are getting very strange very
quickly things are fraying apart
very quickly frankly i was not prepared
for how crazy this year would be
but i will be prepared in the future
thanks to ready wise ready wise is the
leader in emergency food supplies and
they have terrific products emergency
meals freeze dried fruits and vegetables
for convenient on the go nutrition
new adventure meals for hiking camping
and other outdoor activities
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable order online and have
nutritious meals
shipped directly to your doorstep ready
wise products are proudly made in the
usa
you absolutely should not have to
sacrifice taste and nutrition with
emergency food ready wise uses
the finest ingredients and latest food
preparation technology
to ensure optimal taste and freshness
each recipe is crafted by a team of
chefs to provide
delicious nutritional meals especially
during critical times with a 99
satisfaction rate with millions of
products sold ready wise has become
the leader in emergency preparedness
this to me
is so simple first of all really wise
tastes great
that's sort of beside the point you just
want to be prepared you just want peace
of mind
ready-wise we'll give you that this week
my listeners can get 15 off
at readywise.com when entering knowles
15
at checkout or by calling 855-453-2945
readywise has a 30 day no questions
asked return policy
there is no risk taking the initiative
to get you and your family prepared
today that is ready
dot com promo code knowles 15 to get 15
off go check it out
six dollars and 38 cents
thank you so much congress thank you i
feel like i'm
a little pauper congress may i have some
more
no you'll want some more a little more a
little more than 6.38 cents per day
please
it's actually going to be less than that
because obviously people aren't going to
get their checks today
who knows when they're going to get
their checks frankly in my view
the president should veto this this is a
ridiculous
ridiculous bill uh senator cruz just i
actually just saw this headline senator
cruz came out against it a lot of
conservatives are coming out against
this this thing is
a disgrace it's an absolute disgrace of
a bill
it's not just conservative republicans
who are opposed to it you've even got
some democrats including maybe our
favorite democrat these days
tulsi gabbard who is having none of this
covid relief bill
hey everybody i just got back from
having
voted on the house floor on this massive
spending bill
i voted against it and i wanted to tell
you why
first of all this bill was over 5500
pages long
we received the text of this bill at
approximately 2
30 this afternoon and we're told we'd
have to go and vote on it
just a few hours later there is no way
that anybody in congress had the
opportunity or the time
to go through and read this bill to know
exactly what was in it
i've been here long enough to see how
provisions are snuck
into these bills in literally in the
dark of night without any announcement
without
telling anyone what is in it and then
rushed through
in the manner that we have just seen
tonight
this is the height of your
responsibility and it is absolutely
no way for the people's representatives
to be able
to represent the interests of the
american people
absolutely true now what tulsi is
focusing on here is the procedural
aspect the formal aspect of this
how the bill was written how the bill
was sent over to congress
how the the representatives had no time
to read it before voting on it
so yeah procedurally that's pretty
messed up there's also substantive
issues with the bill
if you're going to have a relief bill
give people some money don't
don't give them it really not
everybody's going to get the money too
so it's actually
obviously it's going to be significantly
less than this
this uh amount it's not going out to
every single
american and it's just an excuse
basically the congress gives you know
a little pittance of money to the
american people and then they sneak in
all of their preposterous
largely preposterous plans there as well
tulsi has really impressed
a lot of us i think in the past six
months i was not one of those
republicans who was really on board for
tulsi
during the primary there were a handful
of them who said oh you know she's
anti-war i really like tulsi
okay that's fine but she's broadened out
some of her political thought she's by
far i think the most moderate
democrat as a practical matter on
abortion
she's by the way not even just on those
sort of hot button issues
even on sort of slightly more esoteric
issues issues that don't really get a
lot of play
she's come out pretty strongly tulsi
gabbard is now coming out
actually against the federal bureaucracy
the deep state
the administrative state the
conservatives are always
growing on about myself included tulsi
gabbard is going after those
unelected technocrats and implying that
in a free country a free people should
govern ourselves
heartless arrogant unelected cdc
bureaucrats have decided
that the lives of elderly americans just
don't
count now for months the cdc has been
telling us
that the elderly are the most vulnerable
but now they are recommending that a
hundred million
so-called essential workers which means
healthy people
working at everything from liquor stores
to telephone companies
that they can get the vaccine before our
grandparents can
that members of congress like me we can
get the vaccine before
at-risk seniors can people like my aunt
who is is imprisoned in her own home
because of the danger that if she
catches the disease
she could die this is immoral and
bad health policy i'd plan to take the
vaccine but
we'll now stand in solidarity with our
seniors by not doing so
until they can i urge my colleagues in
congress who are under the age of 65 and
healthy to join me
i love it i love i'm still not going to
vote for tulsi gabbard because
she's obviously more liberal than i am
by a lot but i tell you what
if if the election were between tulsi
gabbard and joe biden it would be a
no-brainer
if the election were between tulsi
gabbard and the clintons it'd be a
no-brainer
if the election were between tulsi
gabbard and aoc or bernie sanders or
whoever it'd be a no-brainer
she is saying sensible things and she is
thinking for herself
which raises this question i actually
had a journalist ask me this question
yesterday
if you know assuming joe biden does get
it the court won't come
in and save the day assuming all of that
will there be a new coalition that forms
a kind of political reordering so you've
got the
liberal establishment which is the biden
types aided and abetted by
the squishy republicans you know all the
lincoln project or the romney tie those
guys
do you think that that will be one
coalition and that the woke
left and the kind of i don't know you
could call it red pilled or based right
could they come together and form a
coalition to attack what has been
disparaged as the unit party you know
the
that the bush clinton that kind of thing
i don't think so i think that's fanciful
thinking i think tulsi gabbard is
totally the outlier here
she should be lauded for her efforts but
i i don't think that's going to happen
because
the thing about the liberal
establishment is they give the woke left
what they want
over time slowly the progression of the
liberal establishment for the last 70
years
has been to the left it's never gone
back to the right it is
always more to the left some people like
the aoc types
are impatient they want this to go
faster but
just look at biden's prospective picks
they're very radical people
they're extraordinarily partisan people
they're not interested in unity and
healing which we'll find out later
you've got more prominent democrats and
democrat
helpers calling for republicans to die
like we were talking about yesterday
and you know you've got the occasional
person who's waking up out of this on
the left you know like tulsi gabbard
they're saying wait a second
these technic rats don't have the right
to form our political priorities
this is so far beyond the realm of
science or
figuring out what works you've now got
these heartless
bureaucrats at the cdc telling you
that your granny doesn't deserve the
vaccine
because they they find other people to
be more favored
than these elderly people i don't think
there's going to be any sort of
coalition here between the woke left and
the red-pilled right because
you know the woke left realizes where
their bread is buttered they realize the
liberal establishment is much easier to
work with
and much more likely to give them the
concessions that they want
in the long run you know there there is
a double standard here you'll see it
actually on public health
the way that skepticism of the virus and
the vaccine for that matter is talked
about
will vary depending on which group
you're in if you're in a favored group
you'll be talked
talked about with great compassion
you'll be given a lot of leeway
if you're in a disfavored group if
you're a conservative you'll be mocked
you'll be castigated
you'll be coerced into violating your
conscience
even on even on a matter as private and
personal as
your medical life and medical life is
very personal it is very private
you know sometimes people don't want to
have these difficult conversations
that's why you gotta go check out hymns
hymns is helping guys look
their best all right if you have not
checked them out yet it is time to see
what they're all about
66 of men start to lose their hair
by age 35. this is very scary for me
because 66
of men start to lose their hair by them
i derive 97 of my power from my hair so
i better not lose it
once you've noticed thinning hair
sometimes it's too late frankly the best
way to prevent
more hair loss is to do something about
it while you still have some
hymns was created by a guy who knows
some men's health conversations
that they're a little bit easier online
than they are in person no more
in-person doctors visits or long
pharmacy lines just a
a answer a quick ques a few questions a
medical professional
will review and if they determine that
it's right for you
they can prescribe you medication to
treat hair loss that is shipped
directly to your door it's very simple
you know we should use the technological
advancements
that can help us that are very simple
hymns is just like this
giving you their best offer yet today if
you're not happy with your result after
90 days hymns will give you a full
refund and right now my listeners can
get their first visit
absolutely free go to for hymns dot com
slash knowles kwles
for hims.com knowles prescription
products require an online consultation
with a healthcare provider
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate restrictions apply see
website for full details
and important safety information
remember that's for hims.com
knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
there's a big double standard going on
here so there's a survey
app this of course is a kaiser survey 35
of black adults say they definitely or
probably won't get the vaccine
and frankly i don't blame them there's
an argument now that
because of historical injustices you
know uh black people should be wary of
science but i'm not even just saying
that i'm just saying if you're
perfectly healthy if you're young then
there's not a very compelling argument
for you to go get the vaccine right if
you're
99.7 percent likely to survive the virus
or
or more by the way if you're younger and
healthier then why would you do that
you have greater risks of many other
activities that you go out
all day long if you're in a higher risk
category then maybe it makes a lot more
sense to go get the vaccine
but look that's how conservatives are
talking about this issue
what the left has been saying is if you
are in
any way questioning the absolute
necessity of getting this vaccine
you are an evil stupid uneducated
anti-vaxxer i don't know whatever
whatever words they use
now that's how conservatives are talked
about face the nation on cbs
has the surgeon general of the united
states on surgeon general who has given
contradictory guidance at various times
on the masks and other aspects of the
pandemic
goes on and he says i was actually
pleased to hear this he says he
understands
why some people are skeptical and feel
like they don't need to go get the
vaccine
he speaks about this matter specifically
he's a black guy he's talking
to the black american community he's
saying i i understand
given not just the what's going on right
now but historically
it makes perfect sense for you to be
skeptical of these sorts of
vaccines i've talked previously about
the the history of mistreatment
of communities of color the tuskegee
experiments the terrible
treatment of henrietta lacks and her
family and how they just
took herself without her permission we
need to understand that that distrust
comes from a real
place it actually comes from my office
several surgeons general oversaw for 40
years the tuskegee studies where
treatment was denied to black men
and i walk past their pictures every
single day
when i go into my office so believe you
me this legacy is important to me
and helping restore that trust is
important we've had
many uh people involved in the review
and actually a study participants of
color
okay this is great i like this i like
this is how i want
my appointed officials and the lab coat
people and this is how i want them to
speak to us
i want them to acknowledge that there
are political considerations
that people have every right to take
into account that are not
merely matters of science and therefore
beyond the realm of legitimate debate
that was good i'm glad
that we're talking about the vaccines in
this way
i'm glad we're talking about science
broadly in this way because
these scientific experts work within the
realm of politics and we have control
over politics we the people
except not every group who questions
the lab coat dictators is being talked
about in this way if you
change a channel you go over to msnbc
you listen to chris hayes and his
experts on tv
you get a very different perspective
when it's the conservatives who are
questioning the medical geniuses
we have watched the the sort of
right-wing disinformation machine which
is
enormous and very powerful get behind
the idea that the election was stolen
and fraudulent despite the fact it's a
complete lie and they have
pumped that into the minds of tens of
millions of people and it is an open
question now whether they do the same
the vaccine tonight
uh my understanding is that uh tucker
carlson was was starting to sort of toy
with that right
if they decide to do that uh then
that we will have a real problem on our
hands we're gonna have a real problem if
these
evil oh like tucker carlson could you
imagine tucker carlson suggesting
that there's any reason to be skeptical
of the vaccine
hey buddy the surgeon general of the
united states just said there's reason
to be skeptical
and a lot by the way a lot of
left-wingers have said this but there's
a reason to be skeptical
specifically in the case of if you're
black because there have been these
medical experiments done on black people
and they weren't always aware of what
was going on and that really is pretty
perverse
and and people who had been given public
trust
sometimes violated that public trust
yeah right
so extrapolate that out to other issues
to other authorities to other segments
of the population
double standard you you would never hear
them speak this way
on the left about conservatives the way
that they speak about
i don't whether you're a favorite racial
group or favored sexual grouper
or whichever there's by the way there's
a new standard here on the vaccines
there's that fake republican anna
navarro
who was yelling at marco rubio yesterday
because he got the vaccine you know
damned if you do
damned if you don't you're if you don't
get the vaccine you're imperiling lives
if you do get the vaccine you're taking
it away from people who really need it
anna navarro is now saying people in the
republican party should not get the
vaccine because they supported trump and
therefore they're evil and therefore
they don't deserve it i take it you know
the answer to this question of who
should get the vaccine first is pretty
obvious and that answer does not include
marco rubio
i don't think it should include the
senator's period
particularly listen there's something
that really gets stuck i think in my
crime in other people's cross
at the idea that people who have been
enabling
donald trump downplaying the covet virus
calling it a hoax
who have attended spoken at
encouraged promoted and participated and
so many of his reckless
rallies where people have been packed
like sardines
and have spoken at these rallies knowing
people are there masculists
who have attended super spreader events
at the white house
like we've seen you know so many people
get
infected with covet at them and then and
then
after they've been selfish after they've
been reckless after they've been
serviled to donald trump
then they get to jump the line and go in
front of
people who are in nursing homes and go
in front of people who've been risking
their lives
for 10 months so according to anna
navarro
she's making a simple point right so
let's hear it out let's debate it
according to anna navarro if you engage
in behavior that makes you more likely
to get this illness
then you don't deserve treatment for
this illness
okay that's anna navarro's point of view
what does anna navarro think about aids
what was she saying
during the aids epidemic because right
now she's saying if you engage in
behavior
call it reckless but any kind of
behavior that makes you more likely to
get the illness
then you don't deserve treatment there
are behaviors that make you more likely
to get all sorts of illnesses
use the example of aids people who
engage in those behaviors they don't
deserve treatment is that right anna
navarro is that what you would
somebody tells me that's not what she
would say what if let's bring it back to
covid
what if and i know there's this
brilliant genius medical theory out
there that public health
experts have signed on to actually that
if you go to a conservative rally a
trump rally
you're you're dangerous you're reckless
you're gonna get covered if you go to a
blm riot
you're not you're fine you can't you you
won't even have your covid
counted in the official statistics
according
according to some people that's what
they want so if you go i i dispute this
medical theory that the virus is so woke
that it only affects conservatives
if you go to the blm rally and you get
coveted do you not deserve treatment
you're showing up it's reckless you're
in huge crowds
you're grabbing lots of gucci handbags
and you're probably not wearing gloves
while you do that you know you're
grabbing lots of
sneakers if you're if you're at the
antifa part of those rallies you're
grabbing all sorts of weapons and
throwing them
beating people up so you're having a lot
of contact like with people's skulls you
know between your knuckles and your in
their skulls
so reckless behavior more likely to be
infected do you not deserve treatment no
it is a double standard but as we were
discussing yesterday
it's it's not necessarily hypocrisy
because the left is kind of open about
this standard right they say
yeah certain groups should get special
privileges and certain groups should be
punished
yeah leftists should get to do whatever
they want and conservatives should be
punished
left-wing political agendas should be
called science and beyond the realm of
political debate conservatives
should not even have a voice in the
public square in their own government
george takei took this a little bit
further
george takei do you know he was on star
trek i guess
like 400 years ago and for some reason
he's
he has a voice in public square i don't
i don't know why i've never seen star
trek
and i don't know that i've ever watched
george takei do anything beyond one of
his little social media videos
but whatever he you know he's very
ardent left-wing
liberal and he tweets out quote there
are very very few instances of known
allergic reactions to the kovid covid19
vaccine
but marco rubio has always thought of
himself as one in a million so there's
still hope
it's actually kind of a funny line right
but
and george takei you know he's an
entertainer he's making a political
point here isn't he and the political
point is
i hope marco rubio has an adverse
reaction
to this vaccine and maybe some of these
allergic reactions kill people
so ha ha ha ha i hope
marco rubio suffers an injury or
possibly dies
unity and healing very unity much
healing
you're joe biden this is his new line
right we need unity we need healing come
to
just look concede the election realize
you lost we're probably going to
end the filibuster at a bunch of states
you're never going to win again but
don't worry because we're going to give
you a lot of
unity and healing meanwhile his campaign
manager
and and prospective deputy chief of
staff
says yeah those republicans are all a
bunch of efforts yeah those oh what a
bunch of efforts but don't worry we'll
work with them
that's the sort of unity and healing
that assuming the
election keeps going the way it looks
like it's going after january 20th
that's the sort of unity and healing you
can expect and i do think we need to
we need to be prepared for this i more
than anybody maybe or at least as much
as anybody
i've said don't concede before you have
to let's hold out for this thing don't
give them an extra minute of legitimacy
now you're seeing even some of the most
ardent voices on the right say
that this thing is over up to and
including pat robertson
who is pretty hardcore okay pat
robertson
makes a lot of conservative republicans
blush he is so hardcore
he's also been around politics now for i
don't know 100 years or something i mean
he's
up there in age robertson believes this
election
is over which means we need to start
looking else i don't know where else we
could project our hopes we have to
project our hopes
if they're not happening in politics you
got to project them obviously up to the
heavens
and you could project them up to the
sort of physical heavens
by watching apollo 11 what we saw become
a daily wire insider or above member
right now for 20
off with code watch over at
dailywire.com
subscribe that is dailywire.com
subscribe
get 20 off your membership with code
watch and
access all of our new and existing
content lots of reasons to subscribe you
can become an
elite all-access member you get to hang
out you get to see us we got
the prageru catalog coming to us we've
got uh which includes by the way my
book club show at prageru we got candace
owens coming to us
we've got all sorts of new stuff for the
new year go check it out at
dailywire.com we'll be right back with a
lot more
pat robertson is calling the election
i'm very sorry to hear that because pat
robertson is
pretty tough as nails republican
pat robertson said my favorite phrase
maybe ever
in modern politics this guy said this is
in a 1992 fundraising letter he said
the feminist agenda is not about equal
rights for women it is about a socialist
anti-family political movement
that encourages women to leave their
husbands kill their children
practice witchcraft destroy capitalism
and become lesbians
[Laughter]
you know and you listen to that you say
gosh that's that's uh pretty
pretty radical uh but much like bertrand
russell with the ontological argument
it's easier to think that he's wrong and
to quite point out the flaw in
his logic regardless pat robertson
no squish right he's never been a squish
he says
joe biden is going to be the president i
think it's all over
i think the electoral college has spoken
i think the
the biden corruption uh
has not totally been brought to
uh fruition but it doesn't seem to be
affecting the electoral college
and i don't think the supreme court is
going to move in to do anything
and i think we're going to see a
president biden
and i also think we'll be seeing a
president
campbell harris not too long after the
inauguration of president
biden that is so
depressing but listen to the way pat
robertson's talking at least when he's
opening up here
he's not saying this is what we should
do this is what i hope happens
he's being purely descriptive he's
saying look
there were these avenues to challenge
the results of the election
you could do it in court and you can get
to the legislative state legislatures or
before they send their electors or to
the electors themselves
the court the courts i think have shut
down a lot of cases but in the
in the real tough cases where they
should have taken up the issue
where ted cruz said he was going to go
arguing before the supreme court
supreme court refused to get involved
they want nothing to do with this
they don't want to bush v gore they
don't want the attention so they refuse
to even hear the case so courts are out
you could get to the state legislature
well state legislatures already sent
their electors they didn't decertify the
vote so now what could the electors be
faithless could they could we challenge
the votes in congress in the house and
in the senate
yes there are some members who've said
they're going to challenge the votes
uh the the historical analog for that
would be the compromise of 1877. we
actually covered it on this show i think
we're the only show in politics that was
covering the compromise of 1877
to give some insight into this election
and the sad fact is
it does not seem that there is the
political will to do anything like that
so robertson totally descriptive here
saying
probably it's over but he went further
and and
actually went after trump a little bit
which made me quite
crestfallen with all
his talent and the ability of to raise
money and draw large crowds the
president
still lives in an alternate reality he
really does
people say well he lies about this than
the other but no he
isn't lying to him that's the truth he
had the biggest crowd on inauguration
gay
he had he had more people than ever he
was the most popular
of people of he saved nbc but with the
apprentice you go down the line of
things that
really aren't true and you know people
kept pointing to them but because they
loved him so much and he was so strong
for the evangelicals the evangelists
were with him all the way
but there was something about him that
was good
that god placed him in that office for
the time he's done a marvelous job for
the economy
but at the same time he is very erratic
and he
he's fired people he's fought people and
he's insulted people and keeps going
down the line
so it's it's a mixed bag and i think
it would be well to say uh you've had
your day
and it's time to move on
you've had your day and it's time to
move on this this is
really sad it's sad for me to listen to
this
and i'm not even look what if at
robertson's point is
trump's a complex guy and he's got many
great virtues and he's got some flaws
too
that's true uh that describes everybody
except
everybody's got flaws not everybody has
heroic virtues or
record of accomplishment but i see his
point i see i see what he's saying
and this is going to be a question that
that is debated for a while is president
trump
going to continue to lead the party is
he going to run again say in 2024
uh you know assuming that biden gets it
this time or
or not is he is he just gonna go away to
the side
you know i i see i see that there is an
argument i understand the argument of
just go away you've had your time now
it's time for somebody else okay fine
people when they leave the presidency
they just often for ex-presidents it's
good when they go into obscurity
but here's my question who
follows trump who else are there a lot
of people who want to
who has the courage who has the
character who has the husba
to follow trump i mentioned this at the
tpusa event the other day i said
i hope trump lives a very long time i
hope he has a very nice
long life when he when he eventually
goes as we all go
he may give his body to science i hope
he gives his spine to the gop
who's going to take up that trumpian
mantle who's going to fight like trump
fights
who's going to change the priorities
of the establishment and at least fight
the priorities of the establishment the
way
that trump did singularly i don't know
if trump leaves on january 20th
and if someone is willing to step up and
take that mantle
and fight and fight for that make
america great again agenda
then there's an argument for trump you
know supporting that person
if nobody does then i want that fight i
want trump to be fighting from outside
of the office and fighting to get back
in too
a lot remains to be seen
i i don't have a whole lot of confidence
given this
covid relief bill quote unquote that
just came out of congress
i don't have a lot of confidence that
there are a ton of politicians out there
who can step up and who can speak up
and and perhaps robertson would agree i
don't know he hasn't consulted me on
this but
this is going to be pat robertson is a
representative
of a of serious you know
right-wing conservatives not squishy
republicans and of people who take their
religion seriously obviously
pat robertson's been a televangelist for
many many decades
describing the cultural issues the
feminist agenda
making people become witches and things
like that speaking of
the strange sexual agendas eddie izzard
eddie izzard who is a british actor
comedian i guess i've heard the name but
i couldn't really pick him out of a
lineup especially now
eddie izzard is now identifying as a
lady
now eddie izzard apparently has had a
sort of complex
sexual confusion for a number of years
now
but he had just announced a couple days
ago he wants to be called a woman so i
go to eddie izzard's wikipedia page
and i i was not shocked that a
person from show business is confused
about sexuality that is
the rule not the exception what was what
was shocking and scandalizing though is
within minutes perhaps of eddie izzard
making this announcement
his entire wikipedia page had the
pronouns changed from him to her
this is a guy who's been in show
business for decades he's obviously a
dude
no one is confused about he looks like a
dude he talks like a dude he's presented
himself as a dude
until five minutes ago the minute he
says
i'm going to identify as a chick now all
of a sudden
big technology the the enforcers of our
new standards
go in and they change everything and so
this is what i found on wikipedia it
said izzard is genderfluid
and calls herself somewhat boy-ish and
somewhat girl-ish
she uses transgender as an umbrella term
when asked what pronouns she prefers
izzard said
either he or she that was in 2019 so
just a year ago in december 2020 israel
stated a preference for she and her
exclusively in the past israel
identified as a transvestite
and she also called herself a lesbian
trapped in a man's body that's how i
identify too and
a complete boy plus half girl well i
don't identify that way but i don't even
know what that means because that
doesn't mean anything
that is a sort of bizarre flight of
fancy it doesn't mean anything maybe the
guy
is suffering from a serious you know
psychological issue or confusion
but regardless you can't be a complete
boy plus half a girl
you can't be boy you can be boyish and
girlish in that
we all have aspects of our personality
that are
slightly more masculine or slightly more
feminine but you can't be both a boy and
a girl at the same time and a boy can't
become a girl and a girl can't become a
boy
he's a man and we're i i don't even
take issue with the idea that people
would have these delusions or even that
some of their friends and family would
indulge those delusions
my issue is that the established
institutions
wikipedia the mainstream media now
government
uh educational institutions
they are indulging the fantasies
that would be bad enough and worse than
that they
are coercing all of us into indulging
those fantasies too
what do we do about that you know poland
has an answer here
poland came out and just the other day
and
they're going to fine social media
companies this is a bill that's up
they're threatening this they're going
to find social media companies
that censor lawful speech this is not a
perfect analogy
but it's getting at the issue so poland
if there's speech that's legal for you
to say in public according to the
government
then they are requiring social media
platforms
to defend that speech there are going to
be some squishes
or p maybe people who call themselves
libertarian or i don't know whatever
they're going to say they're going to
say this is outrageous
the government has no right to tell a
private company
what they can't enforce their standards
you can't legislate morality you can't
okay whatever slogans or bumper stickers
you want to say the fact of the matter
is
all laws legislate morality every
society
everywhere for all of human history has
had standards
and there are limitations on certain
speech because language is limited
if you call a man he you necessarily
won't call him she
if you call the man she you can't call
him
he if he's he or she you're not saying
anything about that you have to
communicate things
that have clarity words are symbols and
they signify certain things and you do
have to signify certain things
unless you want to descend into
random sort of tribes of animals who
just
babble to themselves all day long but
don't actually have meaningful speech
so you do have to say these things and
politics is much larger
than i think a lot of conservatives have
been deluding themselves for for for
a number of decades now buying into this
kind of pseudo-libertarian notion
that there's no role for the government
if you want to look google's censoring
you google is
and wikipedia and big tech are forcing
you to
violate not just your conscience but
violate your own
eyes and rational faculties and say that
a man is a woman
well i don't know build your own
wikipedia build your own google
come on build your own twitter you have
no right yes you do
yes you do this is the kind of
moral idiocy political ignorance
and cowardice that has allowed the left
to run roughshod over the culture
even when republicans win elections
because all republicans ever are willing
to do
is cut taxes a little bit and by the way
still spend more money
we'll just go into more debt they're not
ever willing to do anything on the
culture and the excuse they've found is
well i can't legislate morality
the left does and the right used to and
every
everyone else acknowledges that all laws
legislate morality but i can't
so we're gonna allow these giant
corporations that have
unprecedented power over our public
square
we're going to let them just
dictate our conversations and dictate
the way that we're even allowed to view
reality i don't think so
poland which has often saved western
civilization
let's not forget yon sobieski the battle
of vienna
several centuries ago coming out
saving western civilization once again
has a pretty grounded view of these
things
let's not forget when the soviet union
invaded
and they're you know trying they're
still trying to batter europe destroy
the western world and what happens pope
john paul ii a polish guy
shows up to poland million polls come
out and they say we want god we want god
that the polls have a
i don't know if it's built into them but
they've got this kind of common sense
and here they're saying we're not going
to let these insane corporations
completely undermine our culture
completely minor undermine our
institution
take over our values that if there is
going to if we are going to have to deal
with what the conservative thought means
in a world after trump hope he gets four
more years or maybe 40 more years
but if he doesn't one thing we got to
take from this guy
is courage and common sense trump
actually gave a good answer on this
it was kind of the wrong answer for
policy on the
transgender question but it was the
right answer for politics he was once
asked what do you think about the north
carolina laws and the bathroom laws he
goes
look i don't know what's going on but
come on what was going on before how did
it work before i don't think this is a
big problem
i don't think transgender bathrooms i
don't think this is the biggest national
problem however it was working before
that's fine
he got the particulars of that issue a
little wrong but he was deferring to
prudence
common sense using the
good brain that god gave you and having
a little courage to that
is going to that will either be the
future of
of the conservative movement or the
conservative movement will
not have a future
that's poland gotta love poland
meanwhile here we've completely lost our
minds the left is getting much more
aggressive
this was actually a story from last week
we didn't get a chance to cover it
but it's ramping up again and so i think
it's it's well worth doing
i i was just flying all over uh flew to
georgia flew to florida
flying back and there you know different
airlines are
more serious than others about making
you wear the mask it's got to go over
your nose they'll come they'll touch you
they'll wake you up
they get you to put the mask up over
your nose which seems counterproductive
to me because if they touch you they're
probably more likely to infect
themselves
in any case an airline united airlines
kicked a family off the plane because a
two-year-old would not wear a mask
listen to this woman's story
we just got kicked off the flight
because our
two-year-old would not put on a mask and
we
tried i mean i'm gonna put a video on
and they're sending all of our bags and
adeline's car seat
to new york and we're banned off of
united forever because a two-year-old
would not put on a mask you can actually
see they recorded a little bit of the
interaction on the airplane
listen to the cold
the the cold lack of compassion
from these people just following the
orders from their leftist overlords
so the guys the guy you know the steward
comes up he says you got to get off
you got to be kidding me sorry sir
and i took that opportunity to see this
i'm literally filling in her face
i gave you an opportunity to put the
mask on your two-year-old you have to
leave the plane sir
you guys do this all the time or what
like what if there's money
this is compliance i'm literally holding
over he's like muzzling his daughter
this is
compliance right here i'm sorry sir
he can't force her
she told us not to do that like six
months ago well never mind sorry
that's what you got to do the left is
getting much much bolder
much much bolder than that
and we we need to i think we need to go
a little further we need to not just say
hey
you do you you choose whatever you want
if it makes you feel better do this do
that
i think we need to be bolder and say no
it's disordered
with few exceptions it is disordered to
wear
masks in public that's what banditos do
that's not what civilized people do
just just like with the mail in voting
it's disordered to have widespread mail
in voting there are limited cases where
it's fine
if you if you're frail or infirm or
you're let's say you're overseas and
maybe then you can have an absentee
ballot you got to request it
so i'm not saying this one-size-fits-all
ideological solution but
generally speaking the masks are
disordered the male in voting is
disordered we need to be able to say
that we need to have the courage to not
just say do whatever you want but
actually
you should do the things that we are
suggesting you do because
we've used our faculties of reason and
our common sense left is getting a lot
bolder bill de blasio
out in new york he's not just saying
look we need for justice we need these
compassionate
policies no he's saying hey we're going
to redistribute all your wealth
to profoundly change the distribution of
resources
i like to say very bluntly our mission
is to redistribute
wealth a lot of people bristle at that
phrase that is in fact the phrase we
need to use
this reminds me of beto o'rourke when
all the democrats are saying we're not
going to steal your guns
no we just want common sense reform
we're against illegal guns that was
always mike bloomberg's line he had
mayors against illegal guns
show me the other group where's the
other mayor's four illegal guns no but
it was never about illegal guns
they just want to make guns illegal and
beto o'rourke comes out he says oh yeah
we're going to take your guns
oh man check out this cool this cool
skateboard
move i don't know what are skateboard
moves i don't know i could is that an
ollie is that one who knows
these guys are getting bold and the
thing is beito o'rourke is a total loser
right he lost the senate they lost the
presidency
bill de blasio's the mayor of new york
that was at one point the most important
city in the country i don't know that it
still is but it certainly was
the left is getting much much bolder and
we need to get bolder
too actually speaking of new york
there is one group of republicans there
that is giving me hope
this would be the white stone republican
club in queens
in new york city they held a christmas
party
and it wasn't on zoom it wasn't a
virtual party it was in person and they
weren't all
masking themselves up and putting you
know saran wrap all over their bodies
they walked around like normal people
and actually
they had a conga line
marching around got that trump flag up
front
some fun hats like little red fedoras
naga hats
a lot of boomers you know it's like it's
not like they're rowdy kids or
this isn't the proud boys you know it's
just
normal people living in new york
dancing around having a nice time
i love it if if you'd played this video
12 months ago if you played it a year
ago there would be nothing
newsworthy about that at all now those
people who are just
having a christmas party and dancing
around in a very sort of modest way
they are radicals they are
conspiracy theorists they are crazy
they're out of their mind they're
reckless aren't they
no they're not they've just
the standards have changed so quickly
that you you may not have even noticed
it while it was happening
and people have just gone along with it
like frogs boiling in water
we should not do that we should do we
should not go along with the new
standards
we should actively buck up against them
and you don't need to be some kind of
reactionary to do that and
fall into all the traps that the left
sets for you you can just go about and
live your life and take off that stupid
mask
and go to christmas parties and see your
family
and wave the trump flag wave the
american flag not be
you know not not be living in fear of
antifa smacking you in the head with a
brick
not don't let them bully you into
submission whether it's antifa or
whether it's those bureaucratic bullies
either
go around live your life
have a little conga line that's that's
the kind of resistance that we're going
to need and it's going to have to be
consistent we're going to need courage
to do it i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. if you
prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there